this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
at ramsey we help people build wealth do
work they love and create absolutely
real and authentic relationships
dr john deloney joins me right now here
on the show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
he has a brand new book out that is uh
going absolutely bananas it's done very
very well thank you to all of you that
have purchased own
your past change your future it's only
20 bucks at ramseysolutions.com
and uh the book tour continues the book
came out one week ago today
and so we are going zoom zoom continuing
to be out there and
having him out on the road meeting with
you people he and in a few minutes is
going to jump in an airplane and head to
dallas texas right that's all right
can't wait man we're gonna have a blast
gonna be a lot of fun and so by the time
you folks in dallas hear this um tonight
he'll already be there so there that's
right we'll be doing media in the
morning and then doing some speaking at
some businesses around town and then
we'll be ready to rock and roll the book
signing tomorrow night so tomorrow night
the book signing at dallas texas that's
wednesday
april 27th 6 p.m the barnes and noble at
preston wood town center on belt line
road in dallas texas now phoenix uh we
had over 100 100 150 folks show up for
the book signing there so uh it was a
mad house and we're going to i'm going
to dallas your your reputation's on the
line here and i'm i'm a texas kid you
can't do me wrong dallas so show up yeah
so we gotta have fun you gotta you gotta
beat phoenix easy and we're throwing
down we're throwing down the gauntlet
here you gotta have more more people
than phoenix had i don't mean phoenix
showed up big time they were awesome
yeah they were a lot of fun it was good
we'll have a blast so and john you'll be
uh answering questions talking signing
books that kind of all kind of fun
things yeah yeah if you haven't listened
yet to the dr john delony show you need
to tune in and uh pick that up uh
millions and millions of listeners
already uh on podcast it is uh a a blast
off podcast that has done extremely well
on ramsey the ramsey networks as well as
this new book so if we were going to
distill down in the next moment or two
what own your past change your future is
about and who it's for what is it
it's for almost all of us um people who
are just trying to figure out what's the
next right thing to do in their life if
you find yourself anxious or spun up or
exhausted or
sitting next to your husband or your
wife and you don't even know if you know
them anymore it's for basically all of
us it's folks trying to say okay the
world has happened to me either two
years ago or two ten years ago or twenty
years ago what do i do next right and um
man that book walks you through how to
own what happened to you and then how to
make the next right decisions moving
forward how to heal
well it's doing really really well
it's highly rated on amazon all week
long and own your past change your
future a not so complicated approach
to relationships mental health
and wellness we've sold tens of
thousands of copies here in the first
week
that it has gone out and i'd love to
break a hundred thousand on it that'd be
pretty cool it'll be fun man yeah the
first week out that'd be neat and um so
it will be on the best seller list we
think it'll probably be number one we'll
see when the best seller list comes out
this week and how it's done but um this
comes down to if you've listened to john
here on this show or on his show and you
said gosh i wish i could sit down
kneecap to kneecap with that guy i think
i could unpack some things about some of
the stuff that's happened to me in the
past the way i'm some of the stuff i'm
dealing with right now um well this is
his uh way of doing that yeah and when
you read this book you will feel like
you're sitting having a cup of coffee
with john i have both read the book and
had a cup of coffee with john so i can
tell you that they are remarkably
similar
and uh so it's uh for better or worse
right but in classic ramsey style it uh
is it's easy it's not mumbo jumbo it's
easy to understand
uh but it deals with the person in your
mirror and gives you some tools to
say okay when i'm anxious this is what
i'm doing or from this trauma that i've
dealt with or these all these negative
people or negative uh events have too
much real estate in my brain how do i
deal with that this morning i was in a
meeting and somebody
that works on the on the team with me
said when i started working with you you
handed me a couple of books and said if
you're going to make sense of what i'm
trying to do
read these
and halfway through the first one it's
like i i don't even know what this
person's talking about and i thought i
had handed them three of the simplest
books right
um from my nerd nerd exactly and uh so
this book was a concerted effort let's
in that person circled back and said i
got this one this one makes sense to me
i understand what you're doing with your
book right yeah and so that was really
the point man just demystify just taking
all the proven stuff that's out there
that's right psychology's such a twisted
weird world and there's so many uh
such a wide spectrum of viewpoints on
how to deal with finance man everyone's
got an opinion on this thing yeah
exactly exactly and there's there's a
there's a path that works all the time
every time and it's not sexy and it's
not
fast and it's the
it's it's it's not gonna it's not gonna
be shiny fireworks in the sky it's just
like it's a decision i'm gonna i want a
better life than what i have i want to
stop family trauma i want to be able to
sleep when i lay down in my bed i want
to be able to laugh when i get up in the
morning right i want to live a different
life than the one i've inherited or the
one i've seen
what percentage of
negative
uh psychological things that people deal
with came from
them being passed down from their
parents and their grandparents and their
grandparents grandparents and so on what
percentage would you say i would say
if not a hundred very very close well i
mean sometimes people just have trauma
happen to them yeah you get you get the
car wreck you get the divorce you get
the abuse those things happen i mean you
know you get mugged right right that's
not life happens you know then that that
trauma can throw you off kilter but but
but
how you respond to that trauma is all
based on your story what you see it's
right it's the way mom and dad deal with
um conflict it's the way granddad dealt
with
um issues that were uncomfortable or
with um you know when billy got arrested
or uncle so and so we all uncle so and
so got in trouble at school or whatever
that those are the way we learned how to
deal with conflict and how to deal with
fights and is that somebody else's fault
or is is he a victim that's right uncle
crazy's a victim or is it or uncle
crazy's crazy there you go you know and
how you handle that some parents fought
in front of their kids and now there's
some research that suggests that
um having disagreements in front of your
kids is actually good because then they
get to see the disagreement and then the
reconciliation healthy conflict yeah not
idiotic throwing stuff and yeah
yeah but that conflict and some of us
grew up my parents took their arguments
to the bedroom and because that was the
narrative of the day don't don't have
disagreements in front of your kids
they'll scare them and now i look back
and think oh the first couple years i
was married when me and my wife would
have disagreement my first thought was i
guess this is over i guess you know
because i don't have a picture of what
that looked like and we had to learn no
this is degree disagreements are part of
two people doing life together here's
how we do that honorably and here's how
we do that working towards something not
just trying to burn each other the
ground so that i think all of us have
stuff that we have just picked up in the
stories we were born into the ones we
were told and then it's our job to look
and say i want a different legacy for my
family i want a different legacy for me
that's what it comes down to owning i've
got to make i got to make some changes
i'm going to own my path that's right
my family you know love them but this
part of it i'm going to own it so that
doesn't happen again this part stops
with me it stops here that's right it
ends here yeah and that can be something
simple
or something really really nasty and
dark that's exactly right either way
everybody in between own your past
change your future dr john deloney will
be signing books dallas wednesday april
27th at 6 00 p.m the barnes and noble at
prestonwood town center on beltline
drive be there wednesday night dallas
you got to turn out you got to beat
phoenix the gauntlet is thrown down john
have a good trip thank you my brother
appreciate you
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
dr john stops by before he jumps on the
airplane and heads to uh dallas texas so
ken will be with us for the rest of the
show thank you for joining us the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five as we talk about doing
work that you love
as we talk about creating real
relationships as we talk about building
wealth imagine the energy of a
jam-packed arena filled with people
ready to experience what it means to
live life to the fullest picture all of
your favorite speakers together on one
stage empowering you with tools and
principles that will create unstoppable
momentum in your life
that is smart conference yep smart
conference is back it's been three years
we're so pumped to get this event back
on the road we're in dallas we're headed
your way saturday's october the 22nd and
smart conference is our biggest event of
the year it's a day long and when you
spend that day with us you will leave
smart
it's that easy you don't want to miss
this
all of the ramsey personalities will be
there speaking on personal growth on
money on millionaires on leadership on
mental wellness on relationships on your
career it's all gonna be there and
you're gonna leave with the knowledge
and the motivation you need to live the
life you want all of us will be there
plus we'll have a marriage segment from
our friends craig and amy groschel from
life church one of the biggest churches
in america one of my good friends he's
one of the top leader pastors out there
and man these really good material on
leadership i mean on marriage and
leadership but this is on marriage so be
sure and sign up for smart conference it
is coming up october 22nd it is not yet
sold out tickets are only 39 it's a
great price for a full day event we
should charge 339 for this event get
your tickets right now before they sell
out go to ramseysolutions.com
slash events to learn
more our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
deal today's question comes from rachel
in alaska my husband is a stay-at-home
dad and i work for a school district we
would like to flip our roles so he's the
provider and i stay at home with our
baby he recently passed an exam to
become an actuary and needs an
internship before an employer is willing
to look at his resume child care here is
non-existent with covet shutting
everything down internships don't pay as
much as i make from my job we own two
homes living in one and renting the
other i'm considering babysitting other
people's kids in our home while my
husband does an internship but there is
no guarantee my husband will find
employment afterwards and the income gap
would leave us unable to pay car
insurance and buy groceries we currently
have twenty five hundred dollars in
savings and sixteen hundred dollars in
our checking no debt outside of the
mortgage can you offer any advice
in trying to make this transition
okay there's a whole lot of stuff here
uh just all over the place and i think
that we're focusing all on all of the
hurdles as opposed to maybe some of the
sacrifices we're going to have to make
that don't require us to sacrifice our
income but other types of sacrifices
the internship
how do we get the internship while he's
taking care of the kids we're going to
have to make some sacrifices find a way
to come up with the money for the child
care for him to get that internship
that's where i would go first if the
internship is what is absolutely
necessary it is the gate if you will to
walk into this future to then get him
employed and you be able to switch to
the life that you want staying at home
then there are ways to find child care
for a season for him to get that
internship and it's just a function of
where there is a will there is a way an
old phrase but it's really true so
rachel um
the bible says are the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks
and the language you're using of
absolutism
is inaccurate
and it says to me that you're a little
bit stuck in victim's side
and i want you to get out of that i want
you to rise above that and say okay
this is hard
but it's not impossible
okay let me give you an example of the
language i'm talking about
coveted shutting everything down child
care here is non-existent
okay what you're saying is is that no
one in alaska keeps children
i'm sorry
it could be very difficult and it could
be very hard to find
and it might be a needle in a haystack
but completely non-existent is an
overstatement that's hyperbole you're
exaggerating
okay
we won't be able to buy groceries
not true
you buy groceries first
you might not be able to pay something
else
but you won't be able to maybe car
insurance i mean that might be down the
line down there but groceries are first
and you'll have the money for groceries
so that's drama
oh we're all going to starve to death
entered into your discussion here that
reveals where your head is on this
instead of trying to figure out a way to
do this you're throwing up as ken said
all the hurdles and all the barriers
that's what this thing drips of as i
read through it so here's the thing this
is going to be a tough season for you
guys
to make this transition it's not going
to be easy
uh he's going to be working extra
delivering pizzas or doordash at night
and you're going to be keeping kids and
you guys are going to be living on beans
and rice and you're not going to see the
inside of a restaurant and it's going to
be really hard but you're going to
search every single rock every timber
every tree that a child care provider
could have possibly hidden behind so you
can keep your job and you're gonna go do
the impossible
because you are a victor not a victim
is it easy absolutely it's not easy
but it's but when you get the other side
of this five years from now and he has
that big job and you're able to be home
with the kids like your goal is and he's
able to be the actuary like his goal is
it will have been worth it when you look
back on it well the scary stuff that
she's talking about here is assuming
that she's going to walk away from her
very good and stable job in the school
district she's not going to do that you
know to your point he's going to go work
at night when she comes home and he's
going to go bust his tail where he's
going to come up with the money for
childcare i know but he's gotta but he's
gotta come up with the money for child
care yeah oh yeah yeah and then he goes
and interns so you gotta find someone to
keep them that's what she's saying
that's the hardest thing but it's just
you find somebody yeah they're there
just keep working it i mean you're
talking to the church you you know you
if your life depended on it right you
could find somebody that's right but
there she's not going to lose her income
she's going to stay in that job while
he's interning
and then then they get to make the
transition there you go that's it
so um let me tell you we always will
participate in something with you that
you're doing that's hard
we believe in doing stuff that's hard
that's worth it yeah we you know live
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else
but living like no one else is
impossible we're not gonna line up with
that one we're gonna tell you no you
still gotta do it that's still how it is
it's still how we did it both ken and i
to get to be doing the things that we do
today and to get to be
uh who we are and and to have had the
successes that we've had in different
areas it's we've all paid a price and
sometimes it was an unbelievable tough
walk and it was hard and it was scary
but all we can ever tell you ken or me
about anything we're talking to you
about is if you do that
it's worth it the other side of the
rainbow it's there it's worth it go do
it tyler is with us tyler's in topeka
kansas hi tyler how are you
doing well dave how are you and ken
better than we deserve sir how can we
help you today
i got a question on student loans with
an expecting uh wife here
um
we are expecting in july
oh 43 000 on student loans
um currently have 30 saved
um
and was wondering with the
with the discussions with the the freeze
right now on student loans
whether we should hold on to that money
until it is required that we pay those
or go ahead and get through delivery and
things with the
our new boy here and
uh then go ahead and make that payment
i'd get through the delivery
and i'd try to have the 43 000 when you
get through
here's the thing all you've got for the
freeze is the interest is frozen so
there's no interest right now
but you're in the middle of a pause on
your baby steps you push pause not play
because you got a baby on the way and we
don't want you spinning down to nothing
with a baby on the way so we're gonna
have this pile of cash till baby comes
now if bait what you're saying is baby
may come two weeks after the freeze and
so you might have to pay two weeks worth
of interest
you're right whoopee
okay yeah it's worth it to have that
pile of money so when baby comes you're
okay just be prepared to pay a little
bit of interest and
the good news is that you didn't have to
pay hardly any because the baby's gonna
come and it's just gonna be a little bit
thank god the whole time it wasn't
building up that could have been
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage reba and michael are
with us hey guys how are you good good
dave how you doing better than i deserve
coming where do you guys live uh just
outside of louisville kentucky okay not
too bad a run to nashville good to have
you and uh how much debt have you guys
paid off it was 138 000 in 10 years i
love it good for you and your range of
income during that decade it started out
around
let's see do you know who the nerd is
now yes i am the nerd so it started out
at 104 000 and then last year was 133.
cool what do y'all do for a living i own
my own business and i clean houses good
i am a truck driver for food service
company excellent excellent good okay so
what kind of debt was 138 000 it was our
house whoa looking at weird people
absolutely thus the decade i get it okay
yeah so tell me the whole story how far
back does all this start uh well our
first big uh what was it called when you
buy a brand new car that's not a good
idea stupid tax there you go
that was our first one about six months
after we got married which today is our
20th wedding anniversary
so um we just kind of kept that around
forever so i think it was around 12
years ago before we were like we need to
be done with this you know
and uh so we got a hold of the cds the
radio program all that stuff
and then uh we decided like we finally
got on the same page so you went through
financial peace universities what you're
saying well we kind of did like the cds
ourselves almost home study yes so we
did that and that's when we finally got
on the same page and we're like okay
let's let's actually do this
um so we got rid of that little bitty
debt i think it was like ten thousand in
like what two months couple months yeah
yeah so i was like i don't deserve a
dead free screen because that was like
too fast so let's wait for our house
so um so yeah we got on the same page
and then decided to tackle this after
that okay just like that huh yeah so we
refunded
we refinanced our house 10 years ago the
uh
the the week that our third daughter was
born yeah and we got it paid off right
before our 10th birthday all right i
like that happy birthday
definitely
i love it she's the debt-free kid there
you go i love it very cool this is fun
you guys all right so basically you
lived the first half of your marriage uh
normal yeah had a wake-up call and said
okay no way and you
blaze through the car debt and then take
tear into the house it takes ten years
yeah that was hard too it is hard very
hard for a long time yeah
saying no you know keeping really old
cars i think our cars are older than our
kids so
you know so now it's like oh we get to
save up and actually get some nicer
things yeah i mean so that's really fun
you know we're always talking about in
these journeys you know what's on the
other side of this for folks right it's
always something a little bit different
you get the kiddos you're talking about
cars but as you look back on that
journey you mentioned a couple times it
was really hard there's some stories
there uh a was it worth it and b
what are you most excited about in this
future of truly being debt free no house
payment nothing
well uh in the immediate future i think
we're going to baby step some of the
things in our house that needs to be
replaced like we're going to start with
a toaster oh and we're going to
work our way up to a little bit newer
cars so that's what i'm really excited
about you you like a good piece of toast
yeah i understand we're heading home
getting me a toaster as soon as i do
this debt free that's awesome
yeah it was it was totally worth it
definitely
it was just hard probably the hardest
thing for me being the nerd is realizing
like my way is not exactly the right way
you know you know kind of slow down and
bring in the free spirit and kind of
work together and realize
it's okay once we finally decide like
okay this is what we're both gonna do
and then go for it
yeah very cool all right what do you
tell people the key
to getting out of debt is you paid off
your house and everything by what age
uh she i just turned 40
and i turned 45 okay if you're really
young you haven't eight four houses yeah
this is pretty cool what's this house
worth
uh i think it's about 200 250 yay
somewhere around there feels pretty good
doesn't it oh yeah
okay so what's the secret to getting out
of debt house and everything a lot of
people think they'll have a mortgage
their whole lives yeah no
you want to take that one um
just really getting on the same page and
deciding what you want to do
and um
i mean that's pretty much it for me i
think by that she means the free spirit
gets on the nerd page i think
and me calming down too you know
i can be a bit intense
yeah so you give a little grace and he
and he tightens up a little bit and we
meet in the middle there
and because we have a shared goal yes
and the goal is uh to be debt-free house
and everything and now you can do
anything you want to do yeah including
get a new toaster yeah yeah there we go
happy about that sounds like a good plan
so if you live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
can get a toaster i thought you were
gonna say if you live like no one else
later you can live and eat toast like no
one is i'm looking forward all of a
sudden i'm thinking about a piece of
toast tomorrow morning i mean it's
something i haven't had in a while come
on
killing me here i'm telling you
who doesn't love a good new toaster
i love it way to go you guys way to go
we're very proud of you all right bring
the kiddos in tell us their names and
ages so we have hannah that's 14. elena
is 12. evie is 10.
and then dylan is 7. all right and so
the 10 year old is ready to go here this
is that's free scream that matches i
love it
very cool i love it good stuff you guys
thank you we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth how you can
too that is the next chapter in your
story you've done all the stuff you're
baby step seven you're ready to go
you're gonna be unbelievably wealthy
it's gonna blow your mind where this
ends up if you stay on track so i'm very
proud of you also a copy of total money
makeover for you guys to give away and
be a blessing to someone stir up a
ruckus somewhere with that for me
absolutely that's what i like doing
stirring up a ruckus i'm pretty good at
it too all right reba and michael hannah
elleny evie and dylan from louisville
kentucky 138 000 paid off in 10 years
that's their house and everything
they're weird people 104 133 income
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how it's done
oh my goodness
that's powerful
okay uh so she cleans houses and he
drives a truck
they're 45 years old and paid for 250
000 house
i don't know what neighborhood you grew
up in but my neighborhood we call that
impressive yes yes
that's pretty amazing oh yeah and so you
know you know you don't have to be
making 500 000 a year some kind of
specialist doctor or something to do
this stuff people are doing it every day
from every walk of life in every area of
the country in every situation they're
making the decision to be intentional
and turn this thing around it's very
very possible
and you know you've got to get on the
same page we always hear that you got to
be on a budget we always hear that you
know you've got a um the communication
in a marriage is always vital these are
the ones that always come up over and
over and over and over and over and over
again you can watch literally now
thousands of debt free screams on
youtube that are posted there and there
is a track that runs through all of them
yeah it's really true and you know it's
always special to see a family with
younger kids
reach this moment this pinnacle
because now we're talking about their
future
and how it affects how they grow up i
mean they have kids that are pre-teens
they've got teens and it changes
everything for this family it's not just
the financial piece i mean that's worth
it in and of itself but the ability to
then craft a future uh
i i don't want people to miss what you
say all the time this idea of live like
no one else live and give that's giving
to their kids that's giving obviously in
their community and i got to tell you i
love that the truck driver and small
business owner you know cleaning houses
uh untold amount of hours she probably
worked and and just uh it's it's a
phenomenal testimony to
struggling now
to prosper later you know and everybody
wants to prosper few are willing to
struggle yeah you got up you got to do
the you got to do the thing man i mean
no one wins on accident
it is a series of intentional decisions
developing into habits
developing into uh just you know
redefining who i am i'm not that person
anymore i used to be that guy but i'm
not that guy anymore and uh i used to be
a guy with a mortgage now i'm not a guy
with a mortgage i like that that's
pretty cool that's pretty cool stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
again coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your questions
about work that you love
how you build wealth and how you create
real
relationships stephanie's with us in
louisville kentucky hi stephanie welcome
to the ramsey show
honey thanks for having me sure what's
up
well um so covent was actually a kind of
lucky thing for us right at the very
beginning
we were able to buy our first rental
property right when rates were low but
before housing prices just skyrocketed
it came with a two bedroom house and a
full three bedroom with an extra office
that they've been using as a fourth
bedroom
double wide
this the regular house it didn't really
need a whole lot of work even though it
hadn't been lived in in a while so we
threw some paint on it
did a couple of small things and i've
been renting it out
i would like to fix up the double wide
it means a lot of work though um and i'm
this since this is
new to me um
my husband grew up flipping houses and
he doesn't really want to participate
beyond like giving advice
so this is kind of my my little project
but i don't really know where
to draw the line as far as
how much to
cash flow for it because
you know at the end of the day it's
still a double-wide um
but i think that it would be
i mean
it's already there um
and i'd like to get more rental income
out of it and i think
you know long term it might be a good
thing
um you know i don't want to be a slumber
but i don't want to
uh make it the taj mahal either because
it's still going to be a 30 year old
double wide so i'm not sure i guess just
how to go about that is there like a
certain number as far as how much i
should put it you know that should be my
absolute cap as far as what to put into
it um
well what you have to find what you have
to consider is is that the long-term
play is the thing's worth zero
yeah that's where it's going yeah i
can't imagine it'll be
there's a day there's a day
they don't go up in value they go down
in value period
yeah okay so there's a day that it's
worth zero so that that tells us that's
a different formula than fixing up the
house which is going up in value okay
yeah and so it's a different different
way of looking at it and so forth what
do you think you could rent it for if it
was fixed up
uh if it's three bedrooms i could
probably get 15 to 18 if it's four um
somewhere in the 16 to 20.
okay let's call let's call it let's call
it we're talking 1500 a month
yeah wow
okay that's an impressive figure
all right so we're going to get 1500
bucks a month um
and uh what would you talk about
spending on it
because basically here's let me let me
let me go ahead and limit you
all right
you want to recoup it fast
with 1500 a month
because your other option is sell it
and move it off the property before it
goes down in value further
yeah if you if you're going to keep it
you're going to burn it to the ground
like driving a car into the ground kind
of thing
and so you want to recoup everything
that you put in it with cash flow off
the rental
and so if you if you're making eighteen
thousand dollars on it and you spend
thirty six thousand dollars on it it's
two years before you can get your money
back and it's not going up in value it's
going down in value so this is a pure
i'm going to trade some cash up front
for a 15 100 a month income that will
last for a while
okay so i'm going to go and tell you
your limit is a max of 30.
okay how much have you got to spend on
it
well i
my gut tells me we've you know i don't
want to put more than about 50 into
we've already got 30 put away um for
just kind of whatever we happen to have
if i were in your shoes i wouldn't put
over 20 25 in it
okay i'm gonna fix it because you're
basically you're trading that 20 25
you're gonna get that back and only then
are you making money and from then on
that's the money that you make until it
goes down to complete seed
and it's going to go down to seed how
many square feet is the double wide
it's big it's bigger than my house it's
1800 square feet okay what could you
sell it for today
um
somebody move it off the property three
to five range because um
someone actually was interested in it
and got a quote for um fifteen thousand
to actually move it
um
it's not really habitable right now it's
got a lot of holes in the walls and um a
skylight that's leaking but if we were
to fix it up would take out i'm gonna
i'm gonna change my mind
this is a piece of trash i'm going to
sell it yeah
okay you don't want to deal with what
this is going to be for the next eight
years 10 years
it's going to be a constant headache
it's not that you know it's just going
to be a problem and it's not going up in
value i'm going to sell it for five i'm
going to take the 30 to 50 that i was
thinking about spending in the wrong
place and i'm going to build a little
property up there or something that goes
up in value that's exactly where i was
leaning dave is what could you build if
you want a rental property that bad what
could you build over time yeah that's
gonna build on the same yeah foundation
that's there well not necessarily well
maybe maybe use the same septic system
or the underground utilities that got
there some of the some of the
infrastructure there
and um i'm just going to be thinking
that way even if it takes me two or
three more years to save up and spend
100 on something up there i don't care
whatever you want to do but i just want
to think i always buy real estate with a
20-year
50-year mindset i never buy it with a
two-year mindset
okay i just don't do it and consequently
the number of pieces of real estate i
have sold
in the last 30 years
is one
two
three i've sold three pieces of real
estate everything else i have bought of
capped
and that that's the way you make money
in real estate you don't make money in
real estate now you can make money
flipping properties but you don't make
money in real estate with double watts
now you do make money in real estate
with double wides uh if you buy them on
cash on cash basis and the cash you put
in you like i know a guy owns a trailer
park okay and that thing prints money
okay but you know he he's got five
thousand dollar trailers right all over
this park you know so like 50 or 100 000
worth of these things sitting there and
the stinking thing's throwing off 50 or
100 000 a year right so he doesn't care
if they're going up in value right he
didn't care if they're going down in
value sure but basically the thing is
gradually deteriorating back to the
earth that's right
that's right it's not going to be worth
it i just wonder with the husband having
a background in this and she's like she
was going to do the work i wonder what
they could build a 1200 square foot
building for i i don't you know it'll
tell you it'll take a lot these days
yeah but yeah but still
yeah i'm just going to go that direction
long term i'm not screwing with this
thing if it's me you do whatever you
want to do i'm not stuck up it's just a
matter of math for me bethany is in fort
wayne indiana hi bethany how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um my husband and i are on baby step
four and five and we've got three kids
um he's looking at a career change that
would take us back to school for about
five years five years what's he studying
a doctorate in psychology society
okay so he wants to be a psychologist
yeah
okay
um
anyway so we're saving to go back to
school um we're assuming that he won't
be able to work full-time while he's in
school so we're just trying to save up
as much as possible why and i was
um he could work full-time and complete
a doctorate in five years sure he could
has he got his undergrad
um yes but it's an engineering so it's a
it's a big career change
okay
well i've i got two little kids i'm
doing this at night and and it maybe
takes me six years but i think you can
do it i think you can do it in four
and do it part time i mean it does not
take that to get a doctorate you've got
to do you got to do some undergrad
studies to get some foundational things
some pre-wrecks under your belt and then
you gotta go do the grad work and and
you know then you gotta go through the
doctoral process and that can take some
time
but uh um i'm gonna roll up my sleeves
and knock this out but i'm not quitting
my job no absolutely not he doesn't have
to do that and you guys need to dive in
and get a lot of research and a lot of
confidence in the clarity behind that
but that's absolutely dave's absolutely
right and it might delay a little bit
but it's also going to the return in
this delay is that there is no
interruption of income and you guys
aren't unnecessarily sacrificing
financially now he's going to sacrifice
some sleep
but it's worth it
yeah you have to go get to live his
dream but yeah i i
no i'm going to sort of goof around at
this and i'm gonna work part-time and my
family's gonna starve while i do it no
not something i'm signing up for yeah no
i think we're gonna i think we're gonna
roll up our sleeves to get some stuff
done here
if that that if again that's what we do
at the ramsey house and that's how we
answer it here this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
live
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality best-selling author
of the book paycheck to purpose is my
co-host today as we teach people how to
build wealth do work that they love
succeed in their careers create amazing
and real relationships and deal with
mental wellness of all kinds this is
your show it's a show about your life
and your money a free call here at eight
eight two five
five two two five now ken you work with
people on their careers being successful
in a job in a
chosen vocation
to live the life that you want from
paycheck to purpose
so that you can be successful and our
heart here at ramsey is to always help
people
be as successful as they can in every
area of their lives and career is one of
them yeah you think about how much time
you spend at work uh in a week a month a
year and over a career it's 90 000 hours
is what the average american will spend
at work well then it ought to be about
more than just money we want you to make
a lot of money we want you to also
experience more meaning so money and
meaning is what we're focusing on
uh on the ken coleman show as a part of
ramsey solutions and you know when we
realized that in many ways it is your
job and the ability to advance
professionally that allow you to get out
of debt faster well certainly those
strategies are why we take that very
special your marriage
your health yeah your all of these
things are interconnected that's right
and when you can get all these things
lined up and aligned
uh with your values then you you know
your stress level goes down your peace
goes up your smile is more often and so
i don't know how much it's exaggerated
because the news these days is pretty
much all written for the national
enquirer by all of these i mean it's all
like drama and hyperbole and everything
it i we do miss walter cronkite but um
true because i mean everything's got a
slant to it and so forth but apparently
at some level anyway based on several
articles that have come out
with elon musk buying twitter that the
uh there's a lot of people that work at
twitter the the woke type people that
are very very very stressed out
very upset
uh melting down
in various ways that they can't work
there if he owns the place it's
absolutely true
washington post reported several
conversations they had with twitter
employees when it was announced
on monday of this week that uh that the
deal was going to go through and were
comments like
i'm so stressed out about this i forgot
i have coveted was a direct quote one
was uh
i literally can't
speak
and yet they were speaking when they
said that um and now it's gotten to the
point that twitter leadership is
actually concerned about this has gone
beyond you know hand-wringing on twitter
itself they took to the platform
themselves and you know uh the sky is
falling um you know all these horrible
things about elon musk who by the way
has stated very clearly that the reason
he wanted to buy is because he he didn't
want anybody's speech
to be altered at all so it's about free
speech but this is apparently a uh an
attack on democracy so here's where we
stand today dave
so twitter leadership has decided that
no changes can be made to the actual
platform at all without the singular
approval of one vice president because
they are concerned this is a public
statement by the company they are
concerned that uh some disgruntled uh
employees would try to sabotage the
product
okay so now we've got some let's just
stop for a second there though right
there i mean
you get past elon musk as a person i
don't know anything about him um makes
battery cars and spaceships right i mean
you got it so you got it i'm not a i'm
not a i'm ambivalent about him i don't
know i don't know enough to say he might
be a great guy he might be a horrible
guy i really don't know
what i'm what the principle i want to
dial in on here is for our listeners
you can take a lesson from this
situation
okay
don't
work
for someone
that you hate
don't work for a company
that you're ashamed of
the leadership or their values
go find another job that's right the
reason is very simple
you will not be good
at what you do
it's impossible to compartmentalize
enough to be excellent at what you do
when you detest
the product
the the owner
the leadership
the you know and because you're not
aligned your values are not aligned and
so all of that to say you're going to
have trouble in a situation like these
twitter employees are in prospering
being successful
if you have this kind of angst
about your new boss that's exactly right
and so uh what you should do is go find
another job yeah it's so simple
and you know you don't have to be
stressed no and be freaked out because
you can be hired in about 20 seconds out
there right now there's a there's a war
on for especially tech people right
that's right and if you know how to work
at twitter somebody will hire you
and but if i don't care you know i think
that mcdonald's makes horrible food then
don't work at mcdonald's
but you don't get to tell mcdonald's how
to work
you know if you want to tell people how
to do stuff then you got to go build you
a company that's correct if you are
actively trying to hurt the company you
are pulling a paycheck from i believe
it's tantamount to stealing it is
stealing i really believe that because
here's the deal the minute you are at a
point where you are trying to hurt the
company that is paying you or you are
feeling any kind of other negative
emotion you will not be able to
handle it you can't keep doing it not
only succeeds but it's just called
cognitive dissonance okay yeah it's two
things in your brain that don't both
they can't both be there at the same
time right and be healthy you've got to
be a psychopath that's to
compartmentalize at this level you
cannot do it right and so to to be
successful in your life embrace the
journey
the thing has changed yeah
and uh you should not work for not for
not for the sake of the people and it's
not a matter of you're protesting by
leaving if you want to say that that's
okay yeah but but the um but but the
deal is
it's not about the company and it's not
about elon it's not about anything it's
about you that's right you
cannot be your best version of you the
most successful peaceful
fun
version of you when you work at a place
that is not aligned with your values you
think they're crooks that's right or you
think they're going to do harm to
society or you think they're a
narcissist or you think they're whatever
you should not work there that's right
and so we have no problem i have no
problem with these young people or
however old they are being so upset
about uh musk taking over uh but you
need to leave you need to leave soon and
so the professional advice here is it's
going to take six months for him to take
over ownership that's what twitter's
board has said so you have six months
and i'm trying to make this relevant to
people that are listening and watching
right now because if something like this
happens if you don't work on twitter you
work it anywhere else and something
joe's hardware story and joe sells it to
henry and you don't like him you don't
like henry well then you should you know
you don't get to tell joe and henry how
to do the hardware doyle deal that's
their business they own it that's right
snowflake yeah so you don't get to tell
them how to do their thing if you want
to tell somebody how to do something you
got to be the boss
that means you got to start something
that somebody can [ __ ] about
you got to grow something that somebody
can [ __ ] about so you got to get up off
your butt and go do something but you
can't you don't get to tell other people
how to do that you don't get to tell me
how to drive my car that's my car no but
you do get to listen unless you're a
policeman then you can but other than
that you can't that's a good point
that's happened before
this is a ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about building
wealth doing work that you love creating
real relationships all right here on the
ramsey show phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five john is with us john's in
tampa hi john how are you
good sir how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
so i have my wife in the background
listening she works at mortgages i'm
prior marine corps veteran we recently
sold our property that we owned and we
stood to gain
175 000 from the property we own another
house
and our goal is to be debt-free we
follow we follow your principles we both
go to church and we have about a hundred
uh about 120 000 dollars in the property
and an 18 thousand dollar car payment
today when i finish work i'll be going
to pay off that car uh
our question uh collaboratively is
do we do a recast and put
fifty thousand
sixty thousand down on the house and pay
it off in a year
or did we go out and pay it off outright
our savings we have about thirty
thousand dollars in savings so
just sort of wanted to hear your
perspective so if you pay it off
outright how much is left in savings
there's about thirty five thousand
dollars you wouldn't have to touch that
um no okay as a whole as a whole there
be okay so why would you not just pay
off your house in your car today
our biggest worries is that if we're in
a if we if we find ourselves
um in a recession or a a housing market
issue we wanted to have money to
potentially go and buy a house on the
cheap potentially a are not refinance
what do you call them a a foreclosure
we just want to hear your perspective
so you would not pay off your house in
order to maybe buy a foreclosure if the
housing market tanks
that that's our idea or our idea is to
have
you know have that amount of money set
aside okay i would tell you regardless
of inflation and regardless of recession
that your best goal your best process
is to never buy a rental property except
with cash and to never do that until
your personal residence is paid for
and so that that set of principles that
i've used in my life and for millions of
other people would lead me to pay off
your house and your car today
so pay pay off the house if it wasn't a
rental property it was a secondary it
was a secondary i would be debt free
before i wrote any checks to buy rental
property and i would only pay cash for
rental property then so the point being
we're going to pay off this other
property we're going to pay off your
house your house you're going to pay off
your car you're going to be a hundred
percent debt free and have 35 000 left
in the bank you've got all of your
income now to start saving to buy a
foreclosure when the housing market goes
down someday i don't know when it's
going to go down
uh not soon enough to change this answer
okay so
what you're saying is give you a call
back in a month and scream on the year
that we're debt free there you go
brother or next week if you want yeah
tomorrow if you want but yeah because
you're debt-free pay off everything
that's what i would do listen
something's
the the uh the worry the angst that you
have around the economy you're watching
the news too much number one you turn
the channel off but number two
uh the worry and the it's real but
there's no sense in just bathing in the
blood every night the blood of the
newscast and so uh uh
uh
you know the angst that i hear what
you're what you don't see coming is that
when you pay off all of this stuff
you're gonna get peace yes
and you don't even realize that that's
there so
because a hundred percent we've done
detailed research 100 of the
foreclosures occur on a home of the
mortgage
it's amazing how that works
suzanne is with us in pensacola hi
suzanne how are you
i'm fine thank you
um
i just turned 74 i'm a disabled vet and
a widow
and the debt i have i'll make a payment
this month it'll be under 3 000
so
if you don't mind i'd like to add
something and that is
my boy my husband met his wife before
they were married and this is what i
told him
i said son you hold the ones you love
with your arms but because we're
christians the lord gave you a divorce
decree that's your waistline not that
you're supposed to use it
but as your grandmother would say my mom
raised seven of us what do you think the
good lord gave you two feet for don't
you think you ought to use them
i said your daddy and i used to at a
time assume we had 48 plus years
so i know finance has placed a lot in
marriage and you're bound to disagree
because you're too individual just don't
forget to speak and you'll come out okay
all right how can i help you today miss
suzanne
my question is i don't understand you
know stocks and bonds and that's my next
thing and it keeps talking about
investing in gold and i don't understand
what cryptocurrency is unless it's by
bitcoins or whatever
so is there a book i can
you know get to help me understand any
of this before i invest
okay
um that's a really good question and it
is the proper question never invest in
something until you understand it that
is a rule
go slow
that's the second rule so that you don't
invest in something you don't understand
if you're going to follow what we teach
and what i personally do suzanne i'm 61
is i don't buy anything
except good mutual funds and real estate
that i pay cash for i don't buy gold i
don't buy silver i don't buy bitcoins i
don't buy anything that has a long track
record unless it has a long track record
that is good
gold does not have a long track record
that is good real estate does
mutual funds in stocks and bonds the
some mutual funds have a good
long track record and so i want you to
buy like you were buying a home in a
good neighborhood
and bitcoin's a brand new neighborhood
that's unproven
it may turn out okay
but it's brand new they the houses all
may fall down too
but
to push this metaphor to the brink but
um
but it's a it's you know i don't own any
bitcoin not one and i don't own any gold
except i got a little bit of a gold ring
from my class ring and that's about it
i'm not even big on jewelry so uh
you know it's pretty simple for dave now
as far as the book to read um
there's obviously entire libraries full
of financial books out there that you
could read and you could really go down
the alice in wonderland rabbit hole if
you want to get a basic understanding of
what i'm saying you could watch the
investment lesson
and it gives you enough detail to
understand how mutual funds work how
stocks and bonds work
so that you could begin to get a grip on
understanding and beginning to talk
about investing i will give you that as
my gift
and uh you can uh sign i will sign you
up for ramsey plus which puts you into
financial peace university you can watch
all the lessons you can do the budgets
in there but certainly jump over at a
minimum and watch the investing lesson
it will show you the abcs of investing
in a way that helps you really really
understand it yeah i think that's really
smart i think she needs a really healthy
dose of weariness don't let anybody look
at you and go just trust me suzanne no
no don't ever trust them make sure that
you understand it from a crystal clarity
that allows you to then be confident and
say this is what i want to do i think
that's the great lesson from dave i
think an investing less is going to give
you the strategy it's very easy to
understand and it's time tested we were
we had a meeting the other day we were
talking about the strategy that you've
been espousing for years i mean it just
flat out performs it works well a guy
can't it does and the guy came up here
at the commercial break just a minute
ago and brought us a book true financial
peace university book from 1997 he went
through the class
uh now a baby steps millionaire oh yeah
and uh the lesson that is in that book
that the three-ring binder that he
brought up here that we used to hand to
build those in the office
because that we were teaching it with an
overhead projector in 1997.
the the investing lesson that is in that
book is very
very similar to the lesson that you will
get on financial peace university today
and that doesn't mean that dave ramsey
has it kept up it means that uh the
advice still works hello that's correct
and it's still what i do to this day
i did it in 1997 personally
um
and you know it's like yeah do you do
that with your own money
yes
i do that with my own money
that's an acid test right there i mean
you should really are you putting your
money in this yeah yeah well
okay
then that makes me think about it
ah good questions miss suzanne you hold
on kelly i'll take care of you
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you are here
landon is with us landon is in san diego
california it says on my screen landon
that you are
debt-free man way to go
that's right i'm i am debt-free now very
cool how much did you pay off
i paid off 147 000
532 and 76 cents good for you and how
long did that take
um it took approximately 22 months good
for you whoa and your range of income
during that time
um started off around 73 000 and by the
very end of the journey got up to about
119
000
cool what do you do for a living
i'm a certified public accountant who
works in a tax good for you okay
okay so in 22 months you barely made
enough to pay off 148 so you must have
had some money in savings or sold
something how did you do this
correct um so i actually am by nature a
favor so i had a really healthy
emergency fund around
um ten thousand dollars at that time and
then i had a bunch of um money tied up
in single stocks in a brokerage account
around thirty thousand dollars
um it took me some time to like let go
of the brokerage account just because
i'm a favor by nature and i just
um
really love spend so much time
accumulating all those stocks all of
those years so it did take me some time
to get plugged in to to really let go of
that amount
cool cool and and then you went on just
beans and rice rice and beans what kind
of debt was 148 000
so 19 000 it was a car loan and then the
rest was all school loans cool
did you keep the car
i did keep the car um i just realized
that the school loans were the prop
the car yeah the car was a big debt but
the school runs where the
um the tail that wagged the dog amen
you're exactly right good conclusion i
agree with you well done well done how
old are you
i'm 25. what made you decide to do this
when you're like 23 years old
um so in my household like my parents
went through fpu
many years ago so your name wasn't like
an unknown
and my home church from time to time
will sponsor
fpu classes
um but like the real
key turn was when i went to the mailbox
one day actually and i got a magazine it
was a
money magazine and it had
your face this crazy guy on there was
cutting up credit cards it was it said
um the debt slasher how broke
millennials are flocking to financial
guru dave ramsey
and is his advice sound and i was just
like
like something just clicked there and i
just had to listen to the show and i was
like is it true that dave ramsey helps
people pay off tens of thousands of
dollars of student loans and i just was
listening binging podcasts after podcast
and i just heard a lot of stories where
people are couples um
singles like me were just paying off
tens of thousands of dollars and i just
it kind of was off to the races at that
point
good for you very cool
very cool well the interesting thing was
that article was written to trash me
yeah yeah it's absolutely right
but it turns you on makes you listen
again because you're a financial peace
baby you came out of a home where
parents did this and you'd remember
hearing it at your church so even that
article turned out to be good for me who
knew so great they trash you and
and then literally and then landon ends
up getting out of debt he's the exhibit
a
yeah you know the you know actually are
you a gen z or millennial
uh millennials yeah you're right there
on the edge so good for you wow way to
go landon you're a stud man you knocked
this out so what is the secret to paying
off 148 000 in 22 months you pull 30 000
out of a brokerage 10 000 out so that's
40. that leaves us 108 to knock out
that's 50 000 a year making 73 to 119.
you were on beans and rice
yeah um i definitely say the bud is
super important um but for me was more
about perseverance and staying dialed
into the plan and the process
since it was never going to be a quick
two to three months
but more of a year's long journey i
think when i first looked at it i was
thinking three years
time frame but um
and you guys always talking about the
show how it's a marathon not a sprint
and it was for me it was looking for
small
wins and momentum boosts throughout the
past two years um
i think things from going from asking my
manager my boss like can i please get
double overtime i get time and a half
can i get any extra hours um
to getting delivering a pizza and
getting a 30 tip those were just little
um victories along the way and i think
the biggest momentum was like listening
to the debt free scream after debt free
screen listening to the podcast
trying to dial in and see if there's
anything i'm missing is there any tips
and tricks that tips or tricks that
other people are doing
that i can apply in my own life from
selling things on ebay or doing amazon
or anything like that
and
i i definitely won't say it was an easy
journey because i think for most of the
process it was
um consistent 80 to 90 hour
work weeks
in and out and
there was many nights where i only get
maybe three hours of sleep
and when tax season ended like a lot of
my friends like oh we need to go party
we need to go drink and i was just like
no i gotta
go do my food delivery job from like six
o'clock to 12 to midnight every night so
it was definitely about staying
consistent staying dialed in
and i think
the the major momentum boost for me
probably was around
the two-thirds mark so when i was around
50 000
um
when i had 50 000 left i think i was
able to switch jobs at that point i got
a really good buying bonus and a pay
raising a promotion that my old job
wasn't going to give me and i think that
was when i truly believed i was i could
see the finish line there
um i think through most of us i was like
yeah i think i can do i'm just going to
keep sticking to a plan but it was like
at that moment when i was only 50 000
which sounds like which is still a lot
um but i truly believed in my mind that
i could do this it was just a matter of
time
um and it was going to be no more of
borrowers slaves to the lender and i was
just so fed up of having my entire
paycheck just be eaten by debt payments
my debt payments every month every every
bi-weekly period it just drove me insane
wow
all that sacrifice all that hustle all
that grind how does it feel now that
you're the other side
um i i can't
express enough how the word financial
peace um sounds it it's it's love that
is like when
my first direct deposit and i was like
it was kind of in the mode where i was
going to log on to
sofi and
now it's so long
so long so far i like that i'm going to
keep that one going yeah
so that's where the old student loan was
sitting over there at that wonderful
company called sofi
oh brother wow way to go man way to go
so it was worth it the hustle the grind
the hours now you're free you're 25 and
you're 100 debt free
yes i am way to go brother very proud of
you we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth how you can
too i definitely think your that is your
uh future i will predict that for you
it's it's coming your way also a copy
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone stir up a ruckus as
you've been talking about this who was
your biggest cheerleader as you went
along
um i think it was my parents and my
immediate family um
they were very supportive and they would
always ask like how much how much how
much you've gotten down how much how
much
student loans are left yeah your mom and
dad got to be proud of you man you're a
stud yeah yeah well done and then i i
told my friends and they were all like a
little skeptical at first and but they
would they were supportive and they
weren't like encouraging me to do um go
out and spend all my money
so
very good
cool stuff man all right landon in san
diego 148 000 paid off in 22 months
73 up to 119 with a raise and delivering
some pizzas count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done
so we need to change our tagline around
here
the ramsey show getting people dead free
for generations that's exactly right
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose
as we talk to you about building wealth
doing work that you love and creating
and having amazing real
relationships half of americans over 65
years old will need long-term care and
the average cost of that care is over a
hundred thousand dollars you got a plan
for your long-term care needs now i talk
to people all the time whose time
all the time whose plan is is to let
medicare pay for it i got news for you
people medicare won't pay for everything
and that's why i recommend long-term
care insurance for people age 60 and
over it helps pay for nursing home care
assisted living and in-home care costs
like medical equipment helping help
getting dressed eating home
modifications so you can stay safely in
your own home and that way you get to
keep your independence and your savings
long-term care insurance protects your
family too your spouse and kids won't
have to bear all of the financial or
emotional burden of caring for you
and it doesn't burn up and crack and
scramble the nest egg and leave the
other spouse behind with no money so you
need long-term care insurance once
you're 60 years old
our network of endorsed local providers
will help you understand your long-term
care insurance options and find the
right policy for you that's why they're
ramsey trusted because they'll put you
first
no matter what so if you're 60 or over
it's time to connect with a trusted elp
and get your free
long-term care insurance quotes visit
ramseysolutions.com
long-term care will help you out that's
ramsey solutions dot com
slash long term care
jeff is with us jeff is in boise idaho
hi jeff welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon gentlemen uh waited to
call in when both of you were co-hosting
today because it's because of the two of
you that my life has changed your
teachings um i know what you tell people
i'm the one that changed it but finding
you guys and listening to your advice
has really changed my life and i'm
getting my bachelor's degree here in two
more semesters i'll be done been working
full time going to school full time good
cash flowing it
um and so just super excited but
because talking to talked to ken a
couple of times on his show and i
started doing a podcast last year i'm in
my second year this year
it's growing um and i've got
just signed up to do a second podcast to
produce and host that for another guy
that wants to do it
but here's where my question for you
guys today is
i want to write a book a guidebook here
for a sort here in idaho
and i know you guys put a lot of books
out and i know dave you started many
years ago with just one book but um is
it better to self-publish or go through
a publisher
if you're if you know if you're writing
a book especially your first one
starting out
um
if you have a big platform
and uh
a lot of marketing muscle
uh a lot of notoriety and you're gonna
sell a lot of books
you may want to consider a publisher
uh because they will do all of the uh
the business side of publishing for you
meaning print the book ship the books
bill for the books collect the money all
that kind of crap right
um right you know we've grown ours into
a business so we self-publish everything
here but we're actually a very large
publisher uh and we were the seventh
largest uh we were the
number seven of the companies that put
uh
out of all publishers and there's five
really big ones
uh out there
of people that put [ __ ] books on the new
york are not the new york times but on
the best seller list last year so uh we
were number seven uh and so but again
that's we're
a sizable operation so in your case
um i'm going to guess and say
uh
i would start this book with a
self-published
approach
because i think a publisher might do you
more harm than good
uh you might end up buying more of the
books for your own use from the
publisher after you sold it to them
then you then they actually sell
okay the average book in america with a
publisher that goes out sells 8 000
copies
that's the average
um and uh so
most books don't sell a lot of copies in
other words
and the occasional book goes zoom zoom
and uh you know a million copies is
highly unusual
uh so i think ken's paycheck to purpose
is right now uh somewhere around 250 300
000 copies out the door and we started
it last fall but we're a big operation
and we know how to sell books so
highly unusual though so all of that to
say i think i'd self-publish it
and you can control the marketing then
and you can control the cost and you can
control when you want to use the book
for something other than just selling a
book in other words sometimes a really
nice hardback book makes an excellent
business card
to hand to somebody a promotional item
to hand to somebody but if you're buying
your own book for eight dollars a piece
that you could have printed for two
dollars
uh
to give away
that starts to be prohibitive right
makes sense yeah yeah and so like you
hear me giving away a book you hear me
giving away books on the air here for
different things just as a gift to a
caller in different situations i got
about two dollars a piece in those but
if i was buying them back from my
publisher i'd have eight or ten dollars
in them
and that's what i was thinking so it's
it's good to hear your
your perspective on that and i think too
just being more of a it's going to be a
local guidebook i think it would make
more sense so but i was just curious
what your thoughts were because
i know you published a lot of books
because i've read all the ones you put
out so thank you um
check out amazon i'm not a fan of amazon
on everything sometimes they drive me
nuts
uh and i i worry about them in a lot of
ways but in this situation they have a
self-published arm that you can do
publishing on demand meaning you put the
book up for sale on amazon and they
print them as they sell them for you
it's a wee bit expensive per
unit but if you're gonna move like a
thousand units or something
you know it's a lot easier to do that
than it is to go through a publisher or
to go to some printer and try to get a
thousand books printed that'll drive you
nuts yeah jeff if i heard you say
guidebook a couple times i believe i did
in this case before i'd go through the
self-publishing i agree with dave 100
but before i would go through a full
self-published situation i would test
out the concept a little bit uh i would
do uh maybe shorter not a full-blown
trade book and whatever trim size that
is i'm sure you've done your research i
try out some smaller things some blog
posts i want to see what the appetite is
if this sounds like a local published
product i want to test out the appetite
for this and learn some things before i
spend the time and the money
to self-publish a book so i'm not in any
way discouraging you to self-publish but
before that
i would figure out what my local market
is what are people looking for locally
plus we've got tourism coming in
and i would learn a little bit about
that and test some concepts try three or
four five six different maybe smaller
versions so if you were to think
initially of a
maybe a guidebook that has like you know
12 chapters in it do one chapter two and
then and let's see what happens and
let's learn a little bit because i think
that those lessons can be learned
quicker a whole lot cheaper so that when
we get to the stage of self-publishing
now we feel like we've got a market for
this there's a real market for
what we used to call chapter books um my
friend jim collins did a book uh they
called it a monograph and basically it's
like 37 pages it's chapter
and then we did them uh we've done four
or five of them that have done very well
uh quick reads we call them and they're
you know they're they're 30 to 60 pages
something like that so dr john dolone's
book on anxiety redefining anxiety um
we've sold over 100 000 of those uh but
it's like a 50 or 60 page just a little
quick read it's uh and it hit the best
seller list so uh
it was the first little effort he put
out when he first came here um and uh
so we've got a handful of those that
have come out um
and i'd probably i'm with ken i'd
probably it's a inexpensive you don't
even have to you know you obviously
paperback but sometimes you can do a
staple bind on it or it's a fold-over
rather than having a spine to it if you
get keep it small enough and again your
your cost of good soul goes way down you
can publish it locally you can print it
locally there in boise and you don't
have to end up with dealing with some
printer in chicago or something to get
it done and i would even try an e-book
too because an e-book is even less
expensive and if we prove concept now we
can at least you know if you don't do a
bunch of design you just have a lot of
options that i would test first yeah
let's do a lot let's get some proof text
in the marketplace with it i agree it's
good stuff it's a fun business it's a
fun business because very few people do
it well and so uh the
landscape's wide open
we'll see this week when the best seller
list comes out with john's new book hit
the street this last week so there we go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five we help people build wealth
we'll talk about that do work that you
love
we'll talk about that and create real
relationships that really work and we'll
talk about that talk about your life
right here on the ramsey show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
825-5225 kevin starts off this hour in
saginaw michigan hey kevin how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
awesome i just have a quick question me
and my wife are moving into baby steps
four five and six
paid off all our bills um just this past
march and
um question about four five and six is
we're both federal employees um i also
have a military pension spent 25 years
in the army
and we both
um
have five percent going to tsp just to
get that match
and i was wondering um because tsp we've
lost about 10 percent over the last six
or eight months um
should we work on paying off the home
early um instead of going up to 15
or
or do both
i guess
i'm just afraid if we increase our
um
psp to 15 that we're just going to keep
losing
that extra 10 that we're going to throw
in
i don't know what you're invested in the
tsp but the c plan is not down 10 in the
last six months
um so we have
each of us have 60 in the c and
40 and s
and that's down 10 i think you're
exaggerating
now i i just looked at our balances
yesterday and it's
pretty much 10 percent okay
do you really think that that's going to
be that way for the next five years
no okay i don't either i mean the
market's down in general but i didn't
i'm shocked to hear that that mix is
down that far in that period of time i
really am but um i won't dispute you
because i haven't looked at it but the
uh
i know the stock market is down in
general and so
uh right but uh that doesn't keep me
from telling people to invest 15 percent
of their income because that means the
shares are on sale
right and that's everything i've been
reading too
but again before i pulled the trigger i
just kind of wanted to get some korean
reinforcement from yeah i would do the
tsp to the match and then i would do a
couple of roth iras and if that doesn't
get you to the 15 i'd put a little more
in the tsp to get you there but i would
be doing baby step four at 15 of your
income going in
and then you know work on getting the
house paid off beyond that baby steps
four five six right that works
simultaneously which is um what we teach
there
um
again this economy is weird in an
inflationary economy where there's a
labor shortage
we can't get workers in some areas
um
and we're seeing you know people's
paychecks um
going up well wages are up with wages
are way up everybody's saying wages
aren't keeping up with inflation well
yeah some aren't but most are and many
times in many cases wages are causing
the inflation
because every loaf of bread you buy
had to be uh
you know put on a shelf by someone
that's now making twenty dollars an hour
used to make ten dollars an hour
and uh guess what that's built into that
cost of loaf of bread so you wonder why
the loaf bread went up that's what it
was it wasn't the magic bread fairy
that did it it was the cost of putting
the bread on the oh and by the way the
gasoline that our diesel fuel that
delivered the bread
because the biden administration's
energy policies have driven gas they're
responsible for that portion of
inflation the rest of it they're getting
blamed for but they're not responsible
for but either way
politics aside arguing about that
doesn't matter the the bottom line is is
that um and it's very weird in this
situation the stock market's down that's
right because companies a lot of them
are making more than they've ever made
yeah it's just a gloom and doom there's
a black cloud over the market there is
and then there's a lot of headlines out
there you know that tend to make people
freak out you know i saw a couple that
popped up last week uh there might be a
recession and that's gone quiet and i
think what what's important dave i'm
glad you bring up this weird economy is
because we do have some artificial
things that happen as a result of the
pandemic right so you had a lot of
infusion of cash from the federal
government into the marketplace
unemployment uh was up and down now it's
at historic lows wages that are all-time
high the the labor market's going to
continue to be hot but probably for the
next couple of years just because there
still is this gap
uh for employment and they're looking
for companies are fighting other
companies and it's a grand game of
musical chairs if you remember that
elementary school game but
what i know having worked here for
almost a decade
from uh
watching the show before i ever became a
team member here
watching what we teach living what we
teach it is the financial peace
principles the baby steps that allow us
to be in some ways recession proof so
don't freak out about inflation and
recession because what our steps teach i
really believe this is the discipline
and the freedom to be able to pivot when
you need to pivot recessions are real
and so is inflation however when we know
where we're spending the money and we
have some behavior attached to a budget
we don't have to be walking around like
chicken little the sky's falling just
because we see some negative headlines
yeah
yeah
but and here's the other thing that goes
with this and we're not talking really
about kevin's question at that point
um
but back to kevin's question
uh we do not teach to
and have not lived
uh for decades
uh three of them so far
um to uh jump in and out of the stock
market that's right you talk about the
roller coaster
no one gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off the mill the
right so
yeah the market is down right now it is
down uh when will it come back up i do
not know that's right i also try not to
predict the weather
um
and uh those that do predict either one
are scary people
uh because they're wrong most the time
and they get to keep their jobs and it's
amazing to me so um
that is a good one but anyway the uh
yeah that's um
the thing you want to do is you want to
have a long-term mindset
with your retirement planning yes you
put money in mutual funds this month
when it's down
next month when it's up next month when
it's down next month when it's up
and you'll look up
and there'll be a million dollars in
there that's right and you'll be going
well how did that happen yeah and no
blood pressure or indigestion if you're
just if you've got a long-term view
which you teach and we've taught you
don't get all hung up and all that stuff
it's ridiculous how much i don't look at
the daily news on it i just don't even
look at it it's not because i'm scared
of it i just don't care it doesn't
change my decision well at this point
you actually being the model for this
whole thing uh it doesn't actually
matter no because i'm not going to make
a decision based on what it did today
well i want to make a decision what it
does over a long period of time right
but not over what it did today right or
what it did in the last three months and
so i'm not that does not drive my
decision making because i believe in
the value returns on the stock market
over the long haul why do i believe in
that so we've got 70 years with almost a
12
average annual rate of return on the
stock market
look at the s p 500 it's 11.8 percent
for 70 plus years wow i that's extra i
believe in that you know and so if it's
half of that it ain't bad
you know but that's the average so far
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you're here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five
all right guys how many are you thinking
about buying a home
but you're cringing
at the thought of paying off that debt
for the rest of your life
with sky-high home prices some people
want you to believe that a 30-year
mortgage is your only option do not fall
for this
if you're not paying for your home with
cash your next best bet
is a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage where the payment's no more
than a fourth of your take-home pay
you'll pay off your house faster you'll
become a millionaire you'll pay
thousands less in interest and of course
the monthly payment is higher and of
course that scares some people but you
know what
you're ready and if you're not ready you
shouldn't be buying
so
don't be doing financial decisions
fear-based you need to make decisions
that when you make them you do it calmly
with peace
the free mortgage calculator on our
website can help it'll give you an idea
what your monthly payments could look
like
that way you'll know how much home you
can afford
so you can be mortgage-free in 15 years
or less
go to ramseysolutions.com click the free
tools
to use our mortgage calculator and a
bunch of other good stuff and get
confident about buying a home click free
tools at ramseysolutions.com
brandon is in winston-salem hi brandon
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and ken how are y'all doing
better than we deserve what's up
uh all right so i'm just gonna kind of
give a brief overview of my current
situation um my wife and i are currently
in baby step two um we've got about
seven thousand left on a car and then
about 45 left
on
student loans we've been busting through
them over the last year or so um my wife
is now seven months pregnant yay
[Applause]
thank you thank you um
and then she is actually getting ready
to start on her online master's degree
for nurse practitioner school
we
stopped
baby step 2 to save up for the baby a
couple months ago we've got about 6 000
saved up right now
i am expecting to get around a ten to
twelve thousand dollar bonus once i
finish uh the job i'm on um
probably around october time frame
babies due into july
so
i'm just trying to figure out once we
start back up
with
with the baby steps
how much should i should i hold back for
uh the cash flowing of the master's
degree um just maybe a little bit more
padding for having the baby
um this is our first child so i am i am
a little nervous
you don't need any padding for the baby
once the baby's here and healthy you'll
be okay you just start learning the
budget for diapers and formula that's
part of the form product part of the
process
there's not anything that's that's going
to completely
blow your mind they're they're very very
small at this stage they do not eat a
lot
right okay
they'll get around to it but not yet
you're going to be okay now so i'm not
worried about that what's this master's
degree costing
um it's about so right now she's
part-time she's taking about three or
four credit hours a semester
and it's right around
uh about two thousand twenty-five
hundred dollars uh four three
uh credit hours so going up to four
credit hours i'm guessing that'll be
right around three thousand
and what's your household income is
gonna be when she's back to work
so
i i make right around 90 a year um
that's with like vehicle allowance and
phone and stuff like that my base is 80
it all ends up being around 90.
um and then she last year made
right around 50.
she
actually just dropped down this a couple
weeks ago to prn which is just picking
up shifts
um but she is already scheduled out for
two two shifts a week
for the next
uh two months i mean she's in her third
trimester i mean i'm talking about when
she's back to work after baby
so she's making 60 80 000 a year you're
making 90.
right she's actually going to be staying
home so she's we're we're going to or
she's going to stay at home with the
baby okay so she's going to quit work
but go get her masters i'm now i'm
really confused
well
once once she gets her mat and so the
masters is a three three-year program
once it's a it's a dual masters i don't
remember exactly what the two are i know
it's nurse practitioner for like family
and maybe
uh critical care but the question is is
she getting that for the long term after
baby goes to school yeah
once oh so
i'm sorry i thought you meant like
directly after she comes so once she
starts
working again i'm right around 150 000.
no i don't stop stop okay
she's getting a master's now to use it
to win
once the baby is
older uh so probably
maybe two years in the future once she's
been around and then and then she'll
start going back to work and getting
uh
and then we'll send the baby to date
there
i i i'm still confused so two years from
now but it takes three years to get the
masters
you're right i now i'm confused yeah we
shortly yeah shortly after she gets the
master she will okay how long is she not
gonna work
i guess until she gets her masters three
she might still she'll still be picking
up shifts
while she's taking
the master's degree i am so freaking
confused okay well to be fair he is too
he's not even sure what the dual masters
program i think this is a steak dinner
and let's all get on the same page you
guys need to figure this out because i i
don't understand why number one you do
not need to go get a master's to be a
full-time mom
period
if that's the goal if the goal is to
stay home you don't need to do that yeah
pause the masters pause it okay number
two you guys if you are if she is gonna
use it and go back to work
great go get the masters a pa is a
wonderful thing i'm i'm with you on the
the career track is a great career track
if that if she's actually going to be in
that career field then the masters will
roi you'll get a return on investment on
it but otherwise you're just gathering
up education certificates that you don't
need
um and you what are you a thermometer
you know you don't need more degrees i
mean so you but you have if you're going
to use them that's fine i'm game for it
so you guys need to decide that because
that's going to tell you the urgency on
paying for her masters because right now
my urgency is getting you out of debt
yeah so you can breathe
so if i had my druthers based on what i
think i'm hearing but i have no idea
what i'm hearing but what i think i'm
hearing i'm gonna put the masters on
hold get out of debt work a few shifts
be a mom
and once we're out of debt then you can
cash flow she can work a few shifts to
pay for the masters as she goes along
here or there and begin restart the
masters at that point but just going to
collect degrees we're not going to
ramsey doesn't tell you to do that we
believe in education we don't we're not
anti-education but we are against
spending money uh on education that does
not have a marketplace use
and meaning you're not gonna use it and
so people get upset with us for that
deloney and i told a guy the other day
you know he's going to marry this girl
that wanted to go get a degree at a
prestigious university and was going to
go in deeply in debt to do it and she
had no intention on using it all and we
told him she's not marriage material
and so
we got a bunch of hate mail from him but
that's okay
um
because here's the thing we're going to
tell you what we would tell our own son
or daughter what we would tell each
other because we're friends with each
other because we love you and that's
what you're always going to get here
this is just common sense she can she
can go back into nursing once the baby
once they've determined what that time
frame is and then be full time and blow
through that masters you know i mean
that's when we do it but not now they
need that money to be paying off debt i
mean this is not urgent
um
you know but they've got to get on the
same page he doesn't even know what
she's pursuing and why she's pursuing it
now the time the time
matters the the timeline yeah matters
because but my but i would like to see
you if she's not gonna be working for a
while
go ahead and get out of debt and then
cash flow the masters yes that would be
my preference if she's not gonna be
working for a while if she's gonna go
back to work
fairly soon
the and the masters would accentuate
that then we can talk about piling it
all up on top of each other and you guys
cut into the bone on this
but um
that's the process so hey thanks for the
call
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
just found out some big news
congratulations to our team in ramsey
network's production
the
documentary that we released last year
borrowed future just won number one
in the webby awards
under the uh category of documentary
long-form video cat long-form video
category so there you go number one
documentary it's phenomenal i feel like
i should be handing you something right
now like is there an actual physical
webby uh you know like it's on the web
so it's virtual so
that means i got they gave me they gave
me bitcoin actually no not at all i'm
kidding next segment i'll bring some
popcorn in yeah there you go oh there we
go we can have a fight food fight yeah
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage scott and julie are with
us hey guys how are you hi dave hi dave
welcome so good to have you guys so
where do you live we live in bloomfield
hills michigan ah very good very good
well welcome to nashville and here to do
a debt free screen how much did you pay
off we paid off 262 000
in four years and nine months and we
also cash flowed 255 000 in that same
period whoa for what
lots of stuff okay all right uh
145 000 of uh home improvement projects
whoa okay we had thirty five thousand
dollars for
our wedding and ten thousand dollars for
my son's wedding
we had a love letter from the irs for
forty thousand dollars
uh that caused me to completely deplete
my emergency fund which then had to be
rebuilt absolutely and i also had to uh
borrow some money to pay back the irs
and your range of income during this
four years and nine months
188 000 to 480 thousand dollars
okay
what do y'all do for a living
i'm an attorney and cpa and scott is uh
it project manager okay all right so the
jumping income was the combining of the
two households i'm guessing sounds like
you got married and that's why it went
from 188 to 480. it was two-fold
getting married certainly helped
increase the family household finances i
took a new job with one of my clients
that has been very good to us as well oh
very good excellent excellent so how
long have you been married then
we have been married for about 20 months
we had a coveted wedding ah very good
good for you and i'm guessing the way
the story went down that this is the
paying off of the house
it was the paying off of the house you
are debt-free i'm looking at weird
people we are as weird as you can get i
love it okay so
a lot of stuff going on in this story
you guys have been busy bees i'm just
saying there's a lot of things going on
so
back up a little bit and tell me what in
the world happened here
well we're going to start our dave
ramsey journey in 2013. okay which is
when scott and i met okay and
at that time i've always made good money
always took care of my money so i
thought
didn't have bills i did have credit
cards that i paid off every single month
and but i thought everything was good
i had savings um didn't have a lot of
debt
and from our very first
introduction scott and i were talking
about values which included a lot of
money discussions from the very first
day we met wow
and he's a real romantic oh no
definitely we both are we both are so
romantic
all right let's get to the money
well it gets better dave
within the first three months of scott
and i started to date he uh he'd
mentioned that he had followed the dave
ramsey program for a long time
and
right around one three he handed me a
budget worksheet and he said
i've been using this budget worksheet
since 1996 if we're going to be together
is this something you think you are
willing to follow
and will you participate in
following the budget that i've i've done
for years
and like sure
i like the guy why not
lucky for me lucky for me
it was the first written budget i had
done in my in my adult life
and
that was transformative for me
in doing a written budget
and i didn't realize at that time that
scott was just pulling me
very very slowly into the ramsey cult
this is getting better it was a very
slow process it took him about six foot
that's how that's how the best cult
leaders do it i'm just yeah okay yeah
it's gradual
i had no idea what i was doing or what i
was getting into
about a year or so after we had started
dating
i was still using credit cards
got points went on nice vacations with
my points it was awesome
and i paid them off every month i didn't
have a problem
a year into it scott challenged me to
go 90 days without using a credit card
and i'm like okay fine i'll i'll do that
and i stopped using my credit cards and
i shaved 800 a month out of my budget oh
um which was
yes
i don't have a problem no
no i didn't
didn't have a problem at all
90 days later my credit cards were cut
up and i've never used a credit card
since then man he's smooth yeah
yeah he just and he's sitting there
watching you do this for those that
aren't watching the show right now he's
just he just
going i knew it was gonna happen my plan
worked
i love it this is great
the final
step of me
drinking all of the ramsay kool-aid
happened about three years later i was
getting ready to buy a house
the house i was buying was a project
house had not been updated since 1967
and i was getting ready to sign
a construction loan for 160 thousand
dollars in addition to the 262 thousand
dollar mortgage that i needed to buy the
house
and scott didn't say a lot
we weren't married at the time um
he didn't say a lot but just a few
little things
during the loan closing process
and two weeks before we were that before
i was supposed to close on the loan
uh i went to him and i said i can't do
it
i want to buy the house but i don't want
the 160 000 construction loan
and and so i walked away from the
construction loan still closed on the
house but now i had a house that hadn't
been updated since 1967
to renovate
and so that began a journey of saving a
bunch of money
doing doing one bathroom saving a bunch
of money doing another bathroom so for
about two years
it was just
saving as much money as i could to do
the next project wow and and so i did
145 000 of home renovations that's the
cash flow you're talking about that's
the cash flow okay wow i was sky go back
a second 1997
96 96 yeah i just looked at uh i was
looking at the binder today for the
first time in a long time it was july
96. so this i'm teaching financial peace
university with an overhead projector at
this point right in the hotel ballroom
yes and you were there yes wow yeah by
about 300 people a night in those days
and we broke up into small group
discussions around in the sleeping rooms
in the bottom of the hotel right yeah i
don't even think there were 300 i think
the group i had was
35 40 people it was oh wow it was pretty
small real early right oh my goodness
but and all of these years you've been
doing this stuff yeah yeah it works
hiding in the weeds ready to pounce on
julie when the time was right
i like her you know i cut up my uh
credit cards in 1997
and or 96 probably and
i immediately cut hundreds and hundreds
of dollars a month out of my out of my
budget and it was my life was unchanged
other than i had a bunch of extra money
yeah
and so you started living it way way
back there
and have i i assume have lived
completely debt-free
and so the the debt-free scream is about
your households combining and then the
final steps of julie paying this off is
this i'm getting the picture right now
nailed it
tell him what the the aha moment
so so there was an aha moment she she's
leaving out was uh
probably two years in she goes uh
she we start comparing income and and uh
net worth and she was she was very
surprised even though she made way more
money i ended up with a much higher net
worth i suspect
i suspect it's unbelievable i'm about to
run out of time i don't want to lose you
this is great scott and julie detroit
michigan
262 000 paid off in four years and nine
months what a great story count it down
let's hear a dead free scream three
three two one we're dead
[Music]
i love it
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day job 23 10 but
he knows the way that i take when he has
tested me
i will come forth
as gold
phillips brooks said do not pray for
tasks equal to your powers pray for
powers equal to your tasks
okay we ran out of time on that
ken and i got to
spend a little more time with that
couple at the break on that debt-free
scream
so let's unpack that the rest of the way
because it's very interesting actually
oh yeah i think it's a case study in a
sense so
he goes through financial peace
university in 1997 35 people in the room
he said
and i'm teaching it with an overhead
projector and a bad suit and that's how
the whole thing started um
and uh
he was a a saturn a general motors
employee yes that's why he was here in
nashville at the time moved to michigan
back home transferred him back up there
and as he said on the air the surprising
thing was his income was considerably
less than her income as an attorney in a
cpa uh and yet when they actually
compared net worth before getting
married she was kind of blown away
because his net worth was four times
hers
um
and uh and she's a millionaire so he he
went through in 1997
and is uh baby steps millionaire oh yeah
at 4.1 million dollar net worth now
and uh you know i didn't ask his age but
i'm guessing in his 50s probably
something like that yeah and uh might be
40 i don't know but i think he's in his
50s and so um
is he is he he's out there in the lobby
he's in his 50s we gotta we gotta we
gotta i'm going with that sticking with
it okay so i wonder if he has
i want scott if you've got pictures from
that group you gotta we gotta capture
that because i just i think of that
that's probably had a little bit of a
comb over
cause for how many years have you been
saying that projector bad suit joke yeah
it's not a joke it's what was happening
i know but people want to see that suit
yeah but the uh oh there's pictures of
it around here but the uh
uh
the point is i what i was saying you and
i are walking back in i wish i could
have
i wish i had a time machine to go back
and tell that class that that's what's
going to happen to him
and then he subtly works with his new
fiance oh sure marriage
and she gets out of debt she's a
millionaire
uh and but she gets up her credit cards
and following this plan and now they're
going into a whole another mode yeah
with a combined five million dollar plus
net worth
um
and they're going to be worth tens of
millions of dollars but this is what
happens uh if you know and you go i wish
i had known this well he did he did yep
and he did it and he played all the way
through
from 1997.
so uh pretty pretty cool it's amazing
because he showed us during the break
earlier uh his binder and it's literally
put together it's not in tatters i mean
he he lived it and it is pretty
extraordinary if you think back to those
years you know three whole punched all
that stuff by hand
put the lessons into those three ring
binders and slid color
stuff that we ran off at kinko's slid
that into those uh binders bought at
staples is how we used to do that
because you're doing 35 of them you're
not ordering them a carton of them from
chicago you know
so uh you know that's how but it but the
principles were the same that's right uh
and they worked yeah and here he sits
and yet you are
24 years old out there and you want to
argue with this yeah
um when you weren't even born yet when
he started
yeah and so
you know
you know this is what's called a proven
plan and i'm not bragging on me i'm
bragging on the stuff that we teach
works
and there you are so where do you want
to be
a couple of decades from now you know
you you know you really think bitcoin's
going to get you there that's dumber
than a rock
do you really think nothing down real
estate is going to get you there that's
dumber than a rock
you really think index universal pie ins
are going to get you there that's dumber
than a rock
none of these things have any
data points over decades that show you
that you're going to be a
multi-millionaire doing following it
they just don't no
there's no you can't find people out
there walking around with a three-ring
binder from 1997 that did that stuff and
ended up with they're not there
they're not there and so
but this stuff this gods and grandma's
ways of getting a job doing work that
matters same thing you're going to run
into them a couple decades from now
and um
you know uh uh
the person's gonna walk in here and go
you know i was making 15 20 000 a year
heard your radio show i got paycheck to
purpose and i follow this plan they're
walking around an old tattered copy of
paycheck to purpose and they go you know
now i'm making 250 000 a year and i run
three companies you know and it's just
that's that's what you're going to hear
and that's because these proven common
sense
integrity-based values-based
decisions
that we have taught and continued to
teach in every area of life on the
ramsay show and all throughout the
ramsey curriculums
all through here from ramsey plus to
entree leadership elite and all these
different things that we have around
here all have that same net effect they
all are tied back to gods and grandma's
common sense yeah if you want to prosper
there's a process
it's just it's just this apple the the
absolute simple fact that any
prospering in any of your life whether
it's nutrition physical exercise
marriage parenting money
work
there is a process by which
you need to figure out or in this case
ramsey solutions provides you the
process and it's going to allow you to
prosper and quit looking for the
shortcut well that's right that's gosh
that's really the issue there
all right jason is with us jason is in
seattle hi jason welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you dave nice to talk to you a
long time listener um
so um kind of run through
my
my numbers here before i get to my
question right quick because we're short
up on time
okay sounds good so we have a mortgage
of 190 k 1700 a month 15 year 2.5
interest uh student loan debt about 13
500 no car debt no other debt okay um
college college savings for our dollars
like roughly 5k
uh what's your question
so my question is um i'm
potentially got an opportunity to move
jobs but the pay decrease would be equal
to about 33 000 a year why would you
want to do that the reason that
well the i would be going from private
sector to public sector and i would get
a guaranteed pension
um
that's awful yeah
the guaranteed pension is a carrot that
does not actually exist it's not worth
it
because you can grow your income
over the next three five seven ten years
and that's where you invest with the
strategies that we teach here that
pension's not worth what you think it is
not to take a thirty three thousand
dollar hit quite frankly not to take
care of three three thousand and invest
it you'll have a lot more than the
pension right
okay
why right that answers my question yeah
okay yeah take take stay in the private
sector make more money and you handle
your life yes don't look for someone to
give you a life
uh particularly the government
um yeah i think you're gonna have a
whole lot better
result i know you'll have more money if
you put 33 000 away per year than a
pension will ever pay you dave there's a
there's a hook there that that's not
just something that jason asked we were
talking about this the other day uh with
you and the ramsey personalities what is
it about that he's the phrase guaranteed
pension that would make someone consider
a 33 000 hit
um
it's a mistaken view of what a guarantee
is right
um yeah it's i guarantee you if you have
thirty three thousand dollars that when
you put it in a jar you'll still have
thirty three thousand dollars
you know and if you put it in an
investment that went up a little bit
you'd still have thirty three thousand
plus some and you'd have more than a
pension i mean it's a mathematical
guarantee
so but the what you're looking for there
if you're not careful emotionally is
someone else to take care of you
instead of you taking care of it yes i
think that the self-determination
always makes you wealthier
than other people
providing you
the you know what what you need to win
and so if you're waiting on the
government to fix you if you're waiting
on a secure job if you're waiting on
corporate america to fix your life if
you're waiting on your mama to do it
when you're if you're waiting on someone
else to fix your life your life's always
going to suck
and uh we all have a little of that we
all would like to for mama to cook our
bacon and eggs every morning and we
didn't ever have to clean the pot you
know and uh but you know when you grow
up is when you realize you've got to
cook your own bacon names and that's not
picking on somebody has a a job but
don't look for security where it isn't
and it's a misnomer there and
mathematically it's a misnomer
so it's a good question jason thank you
for calling in ken good show today good
show to james to bend to kelly zach in
the booth i'm dave ramsey your host will
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you